l'invité politique de cette édition jean
frédéric poisson bonsoir sports élue
députée de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines du côté de rambouillet vous
êtes aussi le premier adjoint à
rambouillet oui le maire c'est gérard
larcher oui est ce qu il est prévu une
passation de relais avant les prochaines
échéances électorales pas mac de son ce
n'est pas prévu non je vous le disais
c'est le moment ou jamais de nous donner
ce groupe en tout cas il n'y en aura pas
ce soir vous êtes venu sur le plateau
pour évoquer avec nous votre soutien à
jean françois copé dans le cadre de
cette élection pour la tête de l'ump
auparavant elle va évoquer ensemble un
autre sujet celui du mariage pour tous
nous avons appris aujourd'hui que le
projet de loi qui arrive en conseil des
ministres le 31 octobre et qui devait
être débattu début décembre par les
députés seraient reportées au mois de
janvier c'est le souhait du président de
la commission des lois vous êtes opposé
à l'idée de ce mariage pour tous oui
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle le fait
que cette fois repoussée et qui en
exerce l'avion un petit peu plus
longtemps la bonne nouvelle ce serait
que le gouvernement renonce purement et
simplement à ce projet je pense que
compte tenu des conditions dans
lesquelles se sont déroulées aujourd'hui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pardon à la fois
le grand débat public que nous demandons
tous et qui n'a pas eu lieu la
sollicitation des élus locaux que des
milliers de maires commencent à demander
un peu partout et qui n'a pas eu lieu le
référendum que je fais parti dont je
fais partie des soutiens et qui n'a pas
eu lieu ce report d'un mois ma foi est
une manière sans doute de prendre un peu
davantage son temps parce que on
commence à se rendre compte certainement
que ça n'est pas un texte qui donne
accès pour des raisons d'égalité au
mariage à des personnes qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui c'est un texte qui
bouleverse les fondements du mariage
pour qu'un certain nombre de personnes
puissent y accéder c'est pas tout à fait
pareil qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire table
en problème dans ses enquêtes la joie
c'est le mot sexuelle l'adoption ou
l'idée de l'accès à la procréation
médicalement les trois et vous pouvez
ajouter à la fin de la chaîne la
légalisation des mères porteuses parce
que lorsque vous donner l'accès à la
procréation médicalement assistée à des
personnes homosexuelles marié par
définition cet accès ne peut être donnée
que des couples de femmes pour tout un
tas de raisons biologiques que je
prendrai pas la peine d'expliquer ici
évidemment pour les couples d'hommes
pour les raisons d'égalité il faudra
donner à ces accès aux mères porteuses
donc tout ça pose problème pose problème
également ce qui est le coeur du mariage
c'est à dire la présomption de paternité
c'est à dire toutes les conséquences
qu'il peut y avoir sur la filiation et
plus généralement le fait que toutes les
sociétés se sont construites jusqu'ici
sans exception sur
l'union de l'homme et de la femme comme
le fondement même de l'ensemble des
sociétés
c'est sans doute mais d'abord on a assez
peu de recul là dessus on ne sait pas
quelles sont les conséquences à long
terme nous avons auditionné un certain
nombre de spécialistes de
pédopsychiatres notamment pas plus tard
qu'hier avec le groupe ump de
l'assemblée nationale qu'ils ont fait
part de leurs de leurs inquiétudes et
leurs interrogations donc c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliquée qui pose
énormément de problèmes beaucoup plus
que ce que ça a l'air de poser si je
peux dire donc que le fait qu'on se
donne un mois de plus même après ce
n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle mais la bonne nouvelle ce sera
encore une fois que le gouvernement
renonce a purement et simplement à ce
projet du parti chrétien démocrate
christine boutin et qui est à la
présidente de ce mouvement allié
récemment mariage homosexuel et
polygamie c'est ce qu'elle a déclaré au
micro d'europe 1 c'était le 4 octobre
dernier il est vraisemblable locution
n'accepte le mariage homosexuel on saura
mener dans les années à venir a accepté
la polygamie en france vous êtes
d'accord je pense que
le la fonction du mariage c'est aussi
c'est une fonction de limites d'une
certaine façon une fois qu'on a dit que
la limite étant posée et que pour des
questions qui sont à la fois biologique
juridique psychologique sociologique
pour toutes ces raisons là on réserve le
mariage à l'union d'un homme et d'une
femme purement et simplement on a
légalisé d'autres unions le pacs est une
autre forme d'union bref cette limite
qui est posée par la différence des cinq
réduite à deux personnes est en train
d'être supprimée au motif qu' il
faudrait permettre à tous c'est pas moi
qui ai dit mariage pour tous c'est vous
oui non moi je dis c'est vous c'est
fabrice plus rien
encore mais vous pourriez si vous étiez
en situation de fait
donc si vous voulez si la notion de
limites qui qui qui part en même temps
si ces mariages pour tous et si on fait
du mariage
l'institution qui a pour vocation de
reconnaître l'amour que se portent des
personnes un jour ou l'autre il n'ya pas
de raison pour qu'on impose une limite
au nombre de personnes qui sont
concernées battrai pour c'était très
long c'est ça on sait moins c'est que
christine boutin c'est non parce que si
les cautionner vous avez tout à fait
d'accord prenait que c'est compliqué
c'est un sujet qui est compliqué qui
emporte mais cette déclaration de oui
oui bien sûr le sourire et ça pourrait
partir au moment où la limite imposée
par le mariage est supprimée il n'y a
pas de raison pour que on autorise les
mariages à davantage de personnel du
référendum tout à l'heure si ce
référendum était finalement organisés et
si finalement le référendum était
favorable à ce mariage pour tous tel
qu'il s'appelle oui vous vous plairez ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire se plier
est-ce que vous acceptez certains maires
dans certaines communes ont déjà
spécifié qu'il célébrerait jamais de
toute façon ce sera avec amos est facile
pour moi parce que je ne suis pas mère
ça vous a pas échappé non plus donc je
ne sais pas de changer d'air en 2014 oui
mais alors je reviens tu avais pas prévu
pour l'instant non non je ne célèbre pas
je ne célèbre pas ce genre d'union
je publierai d'ailleurs dans la presse
nationale écrite ces jours ci une
tribune pour expliquer pourquoi il faut
dans le cadre de ce projet doit si
jamais nous avions à débattre et à
l'adopter il faut prévoir une forme de
clause de conscience pour les officiers
d'état civil qui ne souhaiteraient pas
le faire davantage que pensent les
autres élus yvelinois de cette question
du mariage pour tous nous avons
recueilli quelques réactions que je vous
propose d'écouter
philippe brillault le maire
divers-droite duchesnay à semer le
trouble la semaine dernière en faisant
voter une motion par son conseil
municipal pour refusé en l'état le
projet de loi sur le mariage homosexuel
une question de société qui semble donc
faire débat et nous avons voulu savoir
quelle était la position des élus de
l'agglomération
il ya d'abord ceux qui sont ouvertement
pour elles ont même affiché en mairie de
guyancourt par exemple un pacs entre
deux femmes ya été célébré c'est tout à
fait juste légitime et c'est simplement
marquer que les homosexuels sont des
citoyens comme les autres n'oublions pas
que ça concerne 100 milles plus de cent
mille couples homosexuels en france et
que en dans le monde onze pays l'ont
déjà adoptée ce mariage homosexuel et
sur 4 continents
il faut donc s'adapter aux réalités une
réalité aussi pour les mères de la
verrière et magny les hameaux à partir
du moment où dans notre société moderne
s'organisent les choix individuels donc
le choix de vivre ensemble quels que
soient le sexe et bien on peut aller
effectivement jusqu'à la reconnaissance
parce que ça donne des droits se sont
dits droit finalement c'est la
reconnaissance des droits ça fait partie
du programme du parti socialiste et donc
de françois hollande et de la majorité
gouvernementale
donc c'est une avancée de la société
vers l'égalité donc c'est le mariage
pour tous n'y a aucun souci pour nous
attrape le maire socialiste affiche une
position plus nuancée pour lui la
question est complexe quant aux élus de
droite de l'agglomération ils sont
également mesurées et en tout cas il
souhaite établir un débat c'est un débat
que j'aurai avec mes élus mais encore
faut-il déjà que nous puissions avoir
des bases de réflexion puisque aucun
texte de loi à ce jour n'a été votée et
en tout cas je n'ai pas vu celui qui est
en préparation
même si michel logis à temps de
consulter son équipe municipale certains
au sein de celles-ci ont déjà pris
position c'est le cas du conseiller
municipal mathieu colombani proche de
christine boutin il souhaite un
référendum mathieu colombani a twitté en
tant que mathieu colombani aujourd'hui
en tant qu élu de montigny il n'a pas
encore participé débat quel qu'il soit
au sein de l'équipe municipale
la question du référendum un autre élu
s'interroge le maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux il estime que ce
débat n'arrive pas au bon moment ce sont
des questions en fait que je me pose en
temps en temps que maire
est ce le moment
de d'aborder ce sujet là alors qu'on est
dans une très grave crise on a dépassé
des trois millions de chômeurs alors la
deuxième question que je me pose c'est à
ton
consulter les maires
ce sont les maires de france et leurs
adjoints qui célèbre les mariages
les attend consulter le maire ump
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous estime
également qu'il y à d'autres problèmes à
régler en france et il reconnaît des
questionnements au sein de son équipe le
débat est donc loin d'être clos une loi
sur le mariage homosexuel devrait être
présenté en 2013